[Music]
just got this from the wall street
journal just seconds ago
possibly the greatest headline written
so far in 2021. listen carefully to this
amazon the company is seeking to
postpone a unionization vote at a
warehouse in alabama
and is asking federal labor authorities
to reconsider
a decision to allow mail-in voting due
to the pandemic
so amazon and its owner jeff bezos one
of the richest men in the world the
funder of so much of the chaos that has
torn this country apart
is against mail in voting when it might
help his
underpaid employees unionize
i wonder why because it abets fraud
maybe he'll come out and tell us so
great
well if there's one thing that people on
tv know for certain
it's that they're better than you are
obviously
that's the subtext of everything over at
msnbc on wednesday
boy they stopped pretending one anchor
there and a part-time blogger
explain why she's so much better than
you listen
the thing the right hates the most about
democrats is that democrats have the
culture
democrats have the culture they have the
hollywood culture
they have the glamorous culture and the
right hates that
they feel that the culture is too woke
it's too multicultural
it's not john wayne anymore there's all
of this multiculturalism and wokeness
and
liberalism and they hate it but they
also
envy it
so i'm glad the racist lady on msnbc can
take a moment and tell us what the right
really thinks
thanks for that i appreciate it but is
that true
is it true that normal people in this
country not just on the right but who
don't agree with
msnbc look at popular culture and say
man that's so impressive if only i were
impressive enough to create that
is that the root of their anger we don't
know the answer so we got in touch with
the man who joins us now adam carol the
author of i'm your emotional support
animal happy to have him here
adam crow good to see you so i just know
i'm just speaking for myself when i see
the kardashians when i tune in every
week i think to myself
you know obviously it's kind of garbage
but i'm mad that i'm not clever enough
to write something like that this is
sort of the modern toll story of the
kardashians don't you feel that way
it's it's all projection tucker i mean
you think about it
we always talk about this they always
call trump
a narcissist but who's the real
narcissist here
who's the ones who are chasing celebrity
who are the ones who are
worried more about how they look in the
public square
who is the real narcissist in this
equation
and it's funny they always think of the
narcissist as the guy
who's big and puffed up and talking
about himself
but i realize that i think joy reid
is a much bigger narcissist than donald
trump
why do you say that i i suspect you're
right i mean and i
i think it's fair to say you know trump
probably falls in the in the spectrum of
narcissism but i but i also think you're
right that
that that woman the racist lady from
msnbc probably even
a bigger one but why do you say that
you know because i think they look at
the entire world
like high school if you really think
about the left and you really think
about the mindset of the left
it's they're perpetually in high school
they never leave high school it's one
big popularity contest
joe biden is the oldest homecoming queen
or king in history it's just
one big extended high school it's like
they never leave high school it's one
huge
popularity contest
so it does seem to me a little bit like
you're saying
the people in charge of our culture are
emotionally stunted and weird
so maybe a lot of what they produce
projects from that
like their own neuroses get projected
forth onto the rest of us who maybe
aren't so neurotic
and and self-involved
yeah it's exactly that i don't think
they've ever left that mentality
and that's what perpetuates it so
if you get outside of that if you start
talking about lowering taxes or lowering
regulation then you get kicked out of
the cool guys club
you get called a racist or homophobic or
xenophobic and you get thrown out of the
cool clique so you can't have
lunch with the cool kids anymore and
everyone in hollywood
is so perpetually worried about being
thrown out of the little lunch circle
that they have to keep beating that drum
if you
if you wonder like why are all these
people saying the same thing
even though it doesn't make sense over
and over again it's a perpetual fear
being
thrown out of the clique
you've been really quick you've been in
hollywood your whole life i mean you're
from there
do you think that part of the anxiety
we're seeing from the taste makers
is them solely recognizing they don't
make the taste quite as much as they
used to they're losing control maybe
that's why they're angry
yeah you know the celebrity endorsement
used to mean something
right now the celebrity endorsement
doesn't mean
anything and as their
power lessons and lessons over the years
i think they
compensate and they sort of peddle that
bike
even harder and what you're seeing and
what you're seeing right now is them on
a
peloton just trying to get up to ten
thousand rpms
getting yelled at by some woman in
spandex pedal herder
i love that image adam crowley great to
see you tonight thank you so much
thank you